[Musica]
il mondo in cui viviamo
va meglio di quanto pensiamo eppure la
nostra percezione è una percezione
distorta e oserei dire antica e come se
noi fossimo rimasti venti o trent'anni
fa proverò a dimostrarvi questo bando v3
dati
il dato sul tasso dei bambini vaccinati
nel mondo è più alto dell'ottanta per
cento arriva all 88 per cento e questo è
un dato dell'organizzazione mondiale
della sanità che è pubblico
questo significa che la sanità di base è
molto più capillare di quanto noi non
pensiamo anche sull'istruzione ci sono
dei dati confortanti nei paesi a
bassissimo reddito piu del 60 per cento
delle bambine riesce a finire le scuole
primarie e badate bene che l'istruzione
delle donne è fondamentale per
l'evoluzione delle società perché donne
che lavorano significa avere forza
lavoro maschile e femminile che si
confronta e che risolve i problemi in
maniera diversa
donne che lavorano significa avere la
consapevolezza di non fare così tanti
figli e quelli che si hanno assicurano
in maniera diversa dal punto di vista
sanitario e dal punto di vista
dell'istruzione quindi si genera un
circolo virtuoso
un altro dato di cui non abbiamo
coscienza è il dato sulla povertà la
povertà nel mondo si è sensibilmente
ridotta addirittura si è dimezzata negli
ultimi vent'anni è passata da un 29 per
cento a un 9 per cento della popolazione
mondiale che vive con meno di un dollaro
e 90 al giorno
lo vedete in questo grafico la pandemia
sicuramente inciderà su questo trend in
discesa
ma è vero anche che è un trend e che
ripresi da questo shock mondiale della
pandemia
probabilmente troveremo il modo per
continuare a far decrescere questa curva
ora però questo dato significa anche
un'altra cosa
il 9 per cento della popolazione
mondiale vive in paesi a basso reddito
tutto il resto della popolazione vive in
paesi a medio o alto reddito e significa
che questi sono consumatori che hanno la
possibilità di acquistare quindi c'è un
dato che non va così tanto bene ed è
fortemente collegato alla ricchezza
generalizzata che in qualche modo
vediamo ed è il dato sulle emissioni di
co2
questo grafico a la decrescita della
povertà che abbiamo visto adesso a
l'aumento dello status ma anche un
aumento esponenziale delle emissioni di
co2 che sono fortemente collegate con
l'aumento della temperatura del nostro
pianeta
ci siamo dati degli obiettivi sfidanti
la commissione europea se li ha dati
paesi nel mondo attraverso l'accordo di
parigi
ci siamo detti dobbiamo neutralizzare le
emissioni di co2 entro il 2050 significa
che quello che mettiamo che va ridotto
deve essere compensato in qualche modo
altrimenti non riusciremo a limitare
questo 1,5 gradi di riscaldamento che se
tocchiamo beh vengono fuori dei grossi
problemi considerate però che nei primi
20 anni di questo secolo 2000 e 2020
abbiamo aumentato la temperatura di 1,25
gradi
abbiamo pochissimo margine per riuscire
a tenere la temperatura sotto quella
soglia
uno dei settori che impatta tanto e che
ci coinvolge tutti è il settore della
moda quella che ormai si chiama fast
fashion perché siamo talmente abituati a
comprare in modo incontrollato i vestiti
che la produzione mondiale
sta scoppiando e ricordatevi che ci sono
tantissime persone che stanno in paesi a
medio reddito che stanno cominciando
adesso ad acquistare tanti vestiti un
miliardo e 200 milioni di tonnellate di
co2 all'anno più dell'intero traffico
aereo mondiale questo è quello che cuba
il settore della moda e l'otto per cento
sul totale globale
ogni secondo un camion carico di vestiti
finisce in discarica o incenerimento
perché uno dei grossi problemi e che noi
produciamo ma poi smaltiamo in maniera
così veloce che non riusciamo a starci
dietro
leggevo la scorsa settimana e sono
rimasta scioccata un articolo che riceva
che in gran bretagna le ragazzine le
giovani che utilizzano tanto i social
network mettono un vestito due o tre
volte perché farsi fotografare con lo
stesso vestito per più di due o tre
volte è quasi una vergogna e non
vogliono passare le foto siamo arrivati
a questo paradosso allora quello che
volevo fare oggi e farvi capire che
invece una via alternativa c'è che
possiamo essere dei consumatori più
consapevoli e lo faccio attraverso
quello che io indosso il pantalone che
vedete un pantalone che io ho adottato
non è un pantalone che ho comprato non è
un pantalone di cui sto la storia
rispetto agli altri capi è un pantalone
che ho adottato in uno swap party nel
2015 lavorava in expo e con le mie
colleghe a volte facevamo questi
aperitivi dove portavamo festivi che
magari avevamo messo uno due tre volte
che non ci piacevano più che non ci
andavano più nella fattispecie questo
capo non andava più alla persona che
l'ha portato io l'ho visto l'ha preso e
lo ha fatto meno fa parte del mio
armadio da cinque anni e lo metto questo
riduce in parte il problema perché il
problema è che solo il 25 per cento di
vestiti che usiamo liri utilizziamo il
restante 75 per cento va direttamente
incenerire o in discarica e un altro
problema è che solo il 12 per cento
della moda e circolare e vedremo adesso
che cosa significa la maglia che indosso
questa maglia sono tre paia di jeans
produzione italiana toscana piccola
azienda che si è reinventata utilizza
quasi esclusivamente filati rigenerati e
questo ha un grossissimo vantaggio
guardate i dati 87 per cento in meno di
consumo d'acqua 77 per cento in meno di
consumo di energia meno 93 per cento di
emissioni di co2 rispetto allo stesso
capo prodotto da materie prime vergini
io credo che non avrebbe non avrebbe
dubbi se dovesse scegliere con questi
dati davanti su quello che volete
acquistare ma il cotone rigenerato e
l'uno per cento del cotone che si
utilizza oggi nel mondo
la stessa cosa avviene con il cotone
organico ora questo penso che se la
prima volta in cui uno speaker altec si
mette a nudo questa è la vera les che io
indosso oggi è una palette fatta in
thailandia
quindi non è un capo made in italy ma
l'ho scelto apposta perché è fatta da
un'azienda austriaca che ha deciso di
produrre in thailandia con lavoro etico
perché la thailandia è uno dei paesi
asiatici dove comunque c'è sfruttamento
delle risorse umane dove le risorse
umane non sono tutelate dal punto di
vista della sicurezza del salario degli
orari di lavoro loro hanno voluto
portare la produzione è lì per far
vedere che si può anche gli farà una
produzione che sta in piedi e sta in
piedi con un lavoro etico lavorano molto
su ridurre il più possibile gli scarti
ma questo tutto il mondo dell'economia
circolare che si occupa di moda lo fa e
utilizzano appunto questo cotone
organico che ad oggi è solo l'uno per
cento nel mondo di nuovo abbiamo 1 per
cento di cotone rigenerato 1 per cento
di cotone organico il restante 98 per
cento e cotone normale che seppur
naturale viene coltivato con dei
grossissimi problemi
diventa lì perché il cotone normale
utilizzo ha un sacco di pesticidi un
sacco di acqua non fa ruotare le colture
e quindi impoverisce il terreno un
terreno impoverito fifa meno co2
è un circolo vizioso terribile questi
sono i dati sul cotone organico consuma
il 91 per cento in meno di acque blu il
98 per cento in meno di inquinamento
delle acque ea una riduzione delle
emissioni di co2
vado avanti con le scarpe che hanno una
storia antica una storia italiana una
storia friulana si chiamano le friulane
venivano fatte dai contadini nel 1800
con quello che trovavano con scampoli
con copertoni delle biciclette con utah
ed erano le scarpe del lavoro fatte con
determinati materiali ma anche le scarpe
della festa è anche le scarpe delle
spose
questa è una produzione piemontese
friulana una piccola produzione
artigianale che ha deciso di riprendere
in mano questa scarpa e in qualche modo
di rispondere alla problematica dei 380
mila pneumatici che dobbiamo smaltire
ogni anno e che non sono rigenerabili
quindi di nuovo incenerimento o
discarica
lo zaino lo ha portato perché fa parte
di un progetto costruito per i mondiali
di cortina 20 21 banner in pvc gli
eventi producono un sacco di banner a
onor del vero il pvc si recupera si
ricicla se effettivamente mandato ha
corretto smaltimento
in questo caso però noi abbiamo preso
questi banner e abbiamo deciso di farne
parte del nostro merchandising
produzione italiana veneta all'interno
di un carcere
quindi anche in questo caso c'è una
forte valenza sociale perché all'interno
del carcere fanno un percorso di
riabilitazione professionale tutti gli
oggetti che vi ho fatto vedere fino
adesso hanno un alto valore sociale un
alto valore ambientale un basso impatto
ambientale
se noi cominciassimo davvero ad
acquistare in maniera più consapevole e
se orient assimo le scelte delle aziende
probabilmente riusciremo sicuramente a
fare dei passi avanti ed è quello che vi
chiedo oggi voi siete tutti dei
consumatori tutti andate a comprare
abiti vestiti zaini la prossima volta
che andate pensate ad oggi e provate a
fare uno sforzo e a cercare dei capi che
abbiano una storia un'anima un cuore un
legame con il territorio perché se io vi
chiedessi che storia negli abiti che
avete probabilmente nessuno di voi lo fa
l'avete acquistata magari è stato un
prodotto con sfruttamento di persone
neanche di bambini di persone
invece secondo me la strada è davvero
questa tentare di essere dei consumatori
più consapevoli e orientare le aziende
perché devono capire che in qualche modo
se vogliamo riuscire a risolvere il
problema del cambiamento climatico
bisogna muoversi tutti l'ultima slide
che ho fatto
è questa perché molto spesso noi
pensiamo che il problema sia un problema
del pianeta oggi tutti sappiamo che c'è
un problema quello dei cambiamenti
climatici che il nostro pianeta non sta
bene ma il nostro pianeta che a 4,5
miliardi di anni
sopravvivere anche dopo di noi il nostro
pianeta evolverà cambierà che si
sciolgano i ghiacciai che aumentino le
temperature che si impoverisca nei suoli
o le discariche utilizzino un sacco di
territorio
il problema è nostro noi siamo su questo
pianeta solo da 2 milioni di anni 22
mila e 500 volte meno della terra se non
facciamo qualcosa subito non per il
nostro pianeta per noi
probabilmente i nostri nipoti di sé
nipoti trisnipoti si troveranno dei
problemi da affrontare
quindi dobbiamo assolutamente prendere
coscienza che il problema è qui e ora ed
è di tutti non è del nostro pianeta
stamattina venendo qui ho pensato ad una
cosa avuto un flash e il flash questo
spero davvero che nel 2050 su un palco
di un tennis in giro per il mondo magari
a treviso salga uno speaker una speaker
e che cominci il suo speech dicendo ma
lo sapete che le cose vanno meglio di
quello che pensiamo lo sapete che la
povertà è arrivata ai minimi storici ed
è il 2 e il 3 per cento lo sapete che il
tasso di vaccinazione dei bambini nel
mondo ha raggiunto il 95 per cento el
istruzione nei paesi a basso reddito il
75 è inoltre lo sapete che le emissioni
di co2 negli ultimi vent'anni si sono
più che dimezzate
ecco mi sono immaginata questo io mi
sono immaginata in platea seduta in uno
dei vostri posti e sicuramente in quel
momento io sarò un'argilla settantenne
sicuramente sorriderò penserò oggi e
penserò che abbiamo trovato una via e
che lo abbiamo fatto e che siamo
arrivati dove dovevamo arrivare
[Applauso]